développement? Je vous propose
de regarder de Budaj Jacaudrey
Charbonneau m'aider à voir Kim
Vermette.
municipalité. Sauf qu'il y a
un problème. Comment développer
♪ ♪ ♪
- Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu,
11e ville en importance
au Québec, située à mi-chemin
entre Montréal et la frontière
des États-Unis. Ils seront
bientôt plus de
100 000 personnes à y vivre.
ALAIN LAPLANTE, maire sortant,
Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu
- On termine 4 années de
croissance économique. La ville
a vu des milions de dollars
d'investissement au cours
des quatre dernières années.
- Le maire sortant se félicite
de son dernier mandat.
Un thème domine sa campagne.
La protection du territoire
et de l'environnement.
- Les compromis ont déjà été
faits à Saint-Jean-sur-
Richelieu, donc il est impératif
de protéger nos terres
agricoles, de protéger
nos milieux naturels.
- On a un grand territoire.
- Son adversaire, Andrée
Bouchard, a une autre vision.
ANDRÉE BOUCHARD, candidate à la
mairie Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu
- Malheureusement, les dernières
années, il n'y a pas eu vraiment
le développement économique
qu'il aurait fallu. On n'a pas
été tellement attirants pour
des nouvelles entreprises,
pour des nouvelles industries.
- Sa priorité : Séduire les
investisseurs et redorer l'image
de Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu.
- Moi je vise l'équilibre.
L'équilibre entre un
développement économique
responsable et un développement
durable.
- Car ce qui a surtout
monopolisé l'attention à
Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu
ces dernières années, c'est
la guerre politique que
se livrent le maire Laplante
et 9 conseillers municipaux
surnommé "le Groupe des 9".
- La ville de Saint-Jean-sur-
Richelieu vit présentement
ce qu'on peut qualifier de
coup d'état politique.
- Au coeur du conflit,
notamment, le terrain de golf
des Légendes. Les propriétaires
veulent en faire un quartier
résidentiel, mais le maire
Laplante s'oppose fermement
à ce changement de zonage.
- Les querelles à Saint-Jean-
sur-Richelieu sont
essentiellement sur
des questions de protection
du territoire. Toute
cette chamaille là a débuté
le jour où le groupe des 9
a tenté de voter une résolution
pour permettre le changement
de zonage.
- Est-ce que les conseillers qui
ont voté en faveur du projet du
maire, Monsieur Grenier...
- Puis il y a eu le congédiement
du chef de cabinet, un de
ses amis, par les élus.
La Commission municipale
du Québec a fait enquête et
parle d'une guérilla politique.
Elle a d'ailleurs suspendu Alain
Laplante 95 jours en 2020,
parce qu'il avait violé le Code
d'éthique et de déontologie.
- On a l'impression qu'à Saint-
Jean-sur-Richelieu, c'est
la controverse, c'est
la bisbille. Les gens veulent
qu'on passe à autre chose.
Un conseil municipal, ça doit
être exemplaire.
- Et les citoyens évoquent
rapidement cette guerre
politique que se livrent
les élus à l'hôtel de ville.
- J'ai un peu de misère avec
le slogan "Rien à cacher",
pas encore fait de ne pas avoir
confiance.
- Se chicaner, c'est jamais
une bonne chose.
- Moi, quand je vais voir
un avocat je paye mes dûs
et lui, autrement dit,
il fait payer ça par
les contribuables.
- La plupart des Johannais
rencontré sont catégoriques :
ils ont fait leur choix.
Les autres ont encore un peu
de temps pour déterminer lequel
des deux candidats à la mairie
ils préfèrent dans cette lutte
qui s'annonce très serrée.
Ici, Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, À Saint-Jean-sur-
Richelieu.